so this is a video that I've been
meaning to make for quite some time
you can tell it's going to be a serious
video because I bought that to find a
decent background what made me make this
video now was a facebook argument
basically there was an argument more of
a discussion I suppose online about
whether it is possible to buy your way
into Oxford or Cambridge and I wanted to
make this video to try and clear a few
things up because there is a really
commonly held stereotype in this country
this this belief the Oxford and
Cambridge have a mission systems which
are tailored towards rich posh people
and every year in the Daily Mail you
will have a story being run about
somebody who's got 15 8 stars at GCSE
and 10 days at a-level and speak six
different languages and they still don't
get in for their course of choice and
the argument is that it's not a fair
system and I'm going to try and argue
that the system is not perfect but the
problems that we see are not coming from
Oxbridge to give you some statistics on
the problem that we're working with in
2013 Oxford released that it took 57% of
its new intake of students that year
from state schools and when I say state
I mean comprehensive grammar 6 from
colleges and academies and few other
institutions and correspondingly that it
took 43% from private schools now this
is a problem because across the whole
country 93% of all sixth form students
are from state schools and the average
across all UK universities for state
school entry was 88% so there's a
massive disparity between Oxford and
other universities and Oxford and the
national population now a few things to
bear in mind for this video firstly this
is a hugely complicated issue and I
can't hope to fully describe it in a
short video if you'd like more
information on access generally I'd
recommend you check out an interview I
did with my friend Ryan Kemp there'll be
a link to that in the description also
to be completely transparent about my
perspective on this I am a successful
applicant to Oxford I went there in 2009
to study physics from a state
comprehensive school and it wasn't a
terrible school we sent maybe one person
a year to Oxford or Cambridge but that
is naturally going to color my opinion
of the admissions process so when we're
talking about Oxbridge is admissions
procedures why do they need to be known
in the first place well because there
are far more applicants than there are
actual places more than ten to one for
most courses and so there has to be some
kind of selection process
now any selection process where they are
selecting people or goods or anything is
open to bias and that bias can be
intentional or unintentional my argument
is that the bias which Oxford has is
unintentional and it is minor is not the
main cause of the problem
so if Oxbridge are picking students from
a larger body of applicants what are
their selection criteria what are they
fundamentally looking for what's in the
university's best interests well the
things which all universities want our
money and reputation and so naturally
Oxbridge are going to want to choose the
students which net them in the long run
the most money and the most reputation
and who is going to do that well they're
gonna want to choose the students which
go through their system come out the
other end and go on to make lots of
money I'm going to do great things and
those people are going to be the people
who are best at their subjects the
people who are best English in history
are going to leave and go on to write
the best novels and screenplays the
people who are best at economics are
going to leave and make the most money
and that is what's going to benefit the
university in the long term the
University and this is not just from my
personal opinion but from multiple
admissions personnel that I've talked to
over the years because I've done this
for several years now the university
wants the best applicants for its
courses and that's a simple azeez people
might disagree with that assertion but
it is just the truth so why then if the
selection process is just looking for
the best students are so many drawn from
the private sector now as I say this is
a hugely complicated issue but I'd like
to highlight three socio-economic causes
for this firstly and I realized this is
quite a sweeping generalization across a
large spectrum of schools if you go to a
private school or I'd also argue a
grammar school you will receive a higher
quality of teaching and you'll be given
access to more and better resources than
if you go to a state comprehensive
school or a state school generally what
I mean by this is that if you take two
people of identical ability in a
particular subject and you put one
through a private school and one for a
state comprehensive school more likely
than not the person who went to private
school will come out with higher grades
and better qualifications than the
person who entered the state
comprehensive that's just the way the
system works in a sense you get what you
pay for and yes there is the point of
natural talent and I argue that that's
more important in the sciences than any
humanities but you need to be trained to
use that talent you need to be taught
techniques academic discipline
to be taught how to apply yourself to
problems and that is just more likely to
happen in a private school than in a
state school secondly by going to a
private school and again arguably a
grammar school as well
you are part of a community which has
sent successfully applicants to Oxford
and Cambridge before and because of that
you'll be able to ask those successful
applicants questions you're gonna be
able to ask them about their interviews
the questions that they were given
you're gonna be able to ask them how did
you feel those questions what did you
wear how did you prepare you're more
likely to succeed by merit of drawing
from other people's successes it's a
positive feedback where success breeds
success and if you go to a state school
where no one's ever gone to Oxbridge
before then unless you go to an official
university event you're not gonna have
the opportunity to talk to a successful
applicant at listen to the fact that I
know some private schools have members
of staff it was solely there to coach
people to get into Oxbridge there's a
whole raft of advantages beside the
academic which are given to people who
go to paid schools than people who go to
comprehensive schools just don't have
access to thirdly I'm more of a
psychological or a cultural issue if you
go to a school as I mentioned before
that hasn't ever sent anyone to Oxford
before you're more likely to think that
it's just not worth your time but it's
impossible that how could I ever get in
because you know it's for other people
whereas if you go to a school that has
successfully sent applicants before
you're more likely to at least apply and
frankly that's half the battle because
if you don't apply you're not gonna get
in as I say that this is a hugely
complicated issue and these are only
three of the issues at hand but these
are issues which Oxford and Cambridge
every year actively try and combat they
come out there and they do access
initiatives outreach schemes they are
not obliged to do this they are going
out there marketing themselves to state
school students because they want the
best applicants as a matter of fact only
I only applied to Oxford because I went
to some of these events I even went on
summer school and it made me think you
know I can maybe get in these
universities are not trying to con
anyone into thinking that they care
about state school students they do
because they want the best applicants
because they want the best students to
go there but that said the admissions
process is not completely unbiased as I
mentioned before any selection process
is going to have an inherent bias
whether that's intentional or not and
the Oxford system
does have a bias towards people who are
good at interviews the Oxbridge system
in case you don't know is that an
applicant will be given several one on
one or one on two interviews with world
leading academics and in some subjects
like physics you also do an aptitude
test now by doing these interviews you
are actively caving people who are good
at interviews and people might be good
at interviews because as in some schools
they are coached to get through their
interviews they may be kids because they
have been given tips by people who have
gone from their school before ensure
it's this positive feedback that if you
go to a school that has sent people
successfully through interviews you are
more likely yourself to be successful at
interview so why do expres insist on
using this interview system well because
sitting down one-on-one with a world
leading academic is how the most
important part of teaching Oxbridge is
done the tutorial or the supervision
system and the universities are going to
be choosing people that will thrive in
that teaching environment they want to
choose people that are going to be
communicative that can articulate their
thought processes to their tutors
because if they can't do that then how
would they benefit from being in a
tutorial if you go to an interview you
can't do that then that's telling you
that you would actually be happier and
would do better at university reduces
more centralized teaching so the
university does use a system of
emissions which is slightly biased but
it's biased with reason and that bias is
not what causes these huge statistical
discrepancies that are reported every
year basically what I've tried to argue
and I hope I've convinced you is that
the universities are not at fault for
these statistics yes there is some
inherent bias in the selection process
as with any selection process but the
fault is in the wider education system
in this country and that's an issue
which I I can't even begin to talk about
I'm not even qualified to begin talking
about but just take away from this video
please the Oxbridge is doing all it can
to try and ameliorate the situation but
it's a big problem it needs time and
it's not going to get better
anytime soon thank you for watching this
video it's been very important to me
because it's been a big issue in my life
but I would really really like to hear
from you guys please leave in the
comments if you have applied to Oxbridge
successfully or unsuccessfully and leave
your experiences of applying do you
think the emissions process was fair do
you think it unfairly favored people if
you haven't applied yet
what is the culture in your school do
you think people think they can get into
Oxbridge is have you had successful
applicants in the past and I suppose
more importantly do you think I'm right
do you think that Oxbridge is fair in
its admissions process I'd really really
be interested to hear from you thanks
for watching